One of the problems that we always have
is that the kind of culture,
uh,
in which save children involved,
um,
it's hard to replicate in our current,
uh,
in our current culture.
So I always say sort of ideally what
you'd have is a six to one ratio where
you could have six grownups taking care
of each child.
Um,
and I mean maybe a better way of putting
it is that you'd have a community of
parents,
you'd have a community of caregivers.
The children are there as part of that
community.
It's not as if anybody is sitting there
and doing a bunch of special things that
are just directed at the child.
So the vision that we have from school,
there's someone who's got this special
responsibility of shaping education of
the child is the vision that is often
imported into being a parent.
So there's some special set of things
you should do,
some,
you know,
flashcards or video or something other
than what you would normally do.
That's the thing that you are supposed
to do to educate the child.
And what the data,
the research shows is that children are
learning from just observing and
participating in the everyday thing was
that people are doing in an incredibly
subtle and powerful way.
So all the conscious,
I mean the irony is that the unconscious
things that you do when you're,
when you're interacting with children
are much more likely to shape and affect
the way they think then any of the
things that you actually consciously
decide to do.
Um,
and I think we have some lovely models
for the way that,
for example,
you know,
my personal favorite is cooking.
So my grandchildren come in and cook
with me.
Children love cooking,
they love being involved in,
there's nothing that seems more
interesting to them.
Then an adult,
she's actually trying to do something,
actually trying to bring something about
and integrating them into that work.
So in a sense in,
in the village,
the line between here's work and here's
children just wasn't there.
Now the question is what do we do now to
try to,
uh,
when that's no longer true,
we are no longer growing up in a
village.
What can we do now to kind of recreate
that situation?
And I think the best preschools
essentially recreate that village for
children.
So what they do is put children in a
context with a lot of adults who really
care about them,
who are,
who are warm,
who were supportive and lots of stuff
for them to play with.
Um,
another thing,
another thing I say sometimes if you
really wanted to know what children,
preschool children,
young children need to thrive.
They need mud,
livestock and relatives.
And those are things that are in sort of
short supply.
But we can try and say a,
a good preschool to replace the mud,
uh,
livestock and relatives with,
good teachers and cocoons and
caterpillars and sandboxes.
But that's much more what young children
are learning for.
Then all the kind of very scholastic
academic activities that parents feel as
if they need to engage in.
And I think that also makes life as a
working parent easier than if you think
that you have one job and then you have
another job to think that,
uh,
you have a job and then you have this
relationship.
This kind of a form of love that you
have with these children that you're
engaged in.
It's not the same thing as work.
Part of the trouble in our culture in
our society is that we measure
everything.
We treat everything as if it's either a
kind of production or a kind of
consumption.
So from that perspective,
either having children is an extremely
badly paid job or else it's an extremely
expensive luxury.
Um,
and caregiving for children and for
people in general just isn't a kind of
production or a kind of consumption.
It's its own thing.
It's a deep,
important part of being human beings
that we make these profound commitments
to other people.
We care about those people.
We do what we can to let those people
thrive on their own terms and in their
own way.
That's a deep thing that we do
specifically about children,
but it's a part of our relationships
with spouses.
It's a part of our relationships with
say,
our parents when they get older and we
have to take care of them.
And it's something that's kind of
invisible in our culture at large
because it doesn't fit into the
production bucket or the consumption
bucket.
One way to think about it is instead of
thinking about parenting,
we should be thinking about being a
parent.
And it's interesting that we don't,
you know,
we don't wive our husbands and we don't
friend our friends and we don't child
our parents.
We wouldn't measure the quality of any
of those relationships by saying,
oh,
let's see,
is my husband actually,
you know,
has he achieved his benchmarks?
Is he better than he was,
uh,
when I married him.
Um,
you work at relationships,
you put time and energy into them,
but you don't think of them as in this
kind of shaping,
uh,
in this kind of shaping process.
And one of the things that makes
caregiving so interesting,
so much more interesting than it is on
the parenting model,
is these deep tensions,
these kinds of paradoxes that come in
caregiving where we have to go from
taking care of the most dependent
creature we know of a human baby who
completely requires us to make decisions
for them too,
to keep them alive.
And the outcome of all that is to try to
create an adult who's completely
independent of us,
who's completely autonomous,
who can make decisions,
including making terrible decisions
independently of us.
In some sense,
if your children don't have the
potential to fail,
then you haven't succeeded as a parent.
Because what you want to do as a parent
is make someone who's independent and
autonomous enough so they can take risks
and taking risks means the possibility
of failure.
That's a really different,
that's a different kind of activity
than,
than almost any other kind of human
activity.
And it's deep and profound and it's a
big reason that human beings have been
able to succeed as well as they have.